a loudoun county father was made the
face of the supposed domestic terrorist
parents and his story is horrifying
raiders coach john gruden resigns after
his old emails are leaked and the new
superman is bisexual i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressivevpn why haven't you gotten a
vpn yet visit expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first your reminder
inflation is running out of control and
democrats are seeking to ram through
another several trillion dollars in
spending they have all sorts of complex
plans to add trillion dollars to the
national deficit and inflation is going
to continue to spiral out of control as
those supply chain bottlenecks continue
now would be an excellent time to think
about diversifying your portfolio at
least a little bit into something that
has never been worth zero i'm talking
about precious metals of course if you
have not yet reached out to birch gold
to diversify part of your ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira go ahead and
do it today text ben do 47 47 47 get a
free information kit on protecting your
savings with gold i buy my gold from
birch gold they have an a plus rating
with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews thousands of
happy customers and this month when you
place an order with perch gold you'll
get a signed copy of my excellent book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps it's a really good book if i do
say so myself text ben 247 4747 to claim
your free no obligation information kit
on holding gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account plus sending this text
is the only way to be eligible for a
signed copy of my book when you place an
order again text ben 247 4747 and
protect your savings today alrighty so
late last night the daily warrior broke
what is
certainly the wildest most insane and
sickest story of the year the reporter
the indomitable luke rosiak excellent
reporter for daily wire he's the one who
broke the story so we've been hearing
for
weeks now about the supposed domestic
terrorist movements in the united states
no we're not talking about the kkk no
we're not talking about black lives
matter writers we are talking of course
about parents who are going to school
board meetings and then saying things
which is super duper scary
and there are certain people who've been
made the face of this supposed domestic
terror movement you know people who have
been treated as though they are a deep
abiding violent threat to teachers and
school boards across the nation well
this is the story according to daily
wire of one of those people his name is
scott smith here's luke roziak writing
and this is a disturbing story and
you'll see why it's so disturbing and
what it really has to do with is the
fact that the elitists in our society
have cut themselves off from the rest of
america and now are attempting to
dictate policy to everyone else at the
cost of human decency
on june 22nd scott smith was arrested at
loudoun county virginia school board
meeting a meeting that was ultimately
deemed an unlawful assembly after many
attendees vocally opposed a policy on
transgender students what people did not
know is that weeks prior on may 28th
says smith a boy allegedly wearing a
skirt entered a girl's bathroom at
nearby stone bridge high school where he
sexually assaulted smith's ninth grade
daughter
juvenile records are sealed but smith's
attorney elizabeth lancaster told the
daily wire that a boy was charged with
two counts of forcible sodomy one count
of anal sodomy one count of forcible
fellatio related to an incident that day
at the school
as a result of the viral video showing
his arrest smith became the poster child
for what the national school boards
association has since suggested could be
a form of domestic terrorism a white
blue-collar male who showed up to
harangue obscure public servants on his
local school board
lancaster lawyer said if somebody would
have sat and listened for 30 seconds to
what scott had to say that would have
been mortified and heartbroken
minutes before smith's arrest the
loudoun county public schools
superintendent lectured the public that
concerns about the transgender policy
were misplaced because the school system
had no record of any assault occurring
in any school bathroom
then a woman wearing a rainbow heart
shirt a left-wing community activist
told smith she did not believe his
daughter he says his rage reached a boil
and he had a heated exchange of words
with a woman a police officer there to
keep the peace in the meeting pulled on
his arm smith yanked it away before he
knew what smith says he was hit in the
face handcuffed and dragged across the
floor with his pants pulled down images
of the incident were splashed on tvs and
newspapers across the world
bhuta bibaraj the county's progressive
top elected prosecutor who has close
ties to the school board's most liberal
members appeared in court to personally
prosecute smith for disorderly conduct
and resisting arrest bibaraj ran on a
platform of ending mass incarceration
but she wanted to put smith in jail for
the misdemeanors
as prosecutor mibaraj would have known
about the case involving smith's
daughter the suspect juvenile court
prosecutors assured smith was being held
responsible he was on house arrest
confined to his mother's townhouse
according to lancaster a conviction was
expected on october 14th likely in the
form of a guilty plea to a lesser sexual
assault charge but on october 6
according to the loudoun county
sheriff's office a 15-year-old was
charged with sexual battery and
abduction after police said he forced a
girl into an empty classroom held her
against her will and touched her
inappropriately
lancaster says the suspect is the same
boy who allegedly attacked smith's
daughter
what follows based on extensive
exclusive reporting from loudoun county
is smith's experience it is a story the
school system and media were never going
to tell
so the short story here and we'll get to
the details in a second is that one of
the parents who was protesting a school
board and was speaking about the threat
of transgender bathroom policy had a
daughter who was allegedly raped in the
bathroom by a boy wearing a skirt
and when he started to say what he
thought people started to get angry at
him and this resulted in him being
branded a quote unquote domestic
terrorist by the media and the face of
this very upset movement
again the father of the girl
here's the story on may 28th stonebridge
high school called smith to come to the
school
they told him his 15 year old daughter
had just been physically assaulted in a
bathroom by a male
when he arrived he determined that what
had happened was not a case of his
daughter being beaten up it was far more
serious the school said it was handling
the incident in-house smith was
dumbfounded
deputies from the sheriff's office
ultimately responded to the school not
to investigate the alleged rape of a
child smith said but because school
administrators called them on him for
making a scene about it
smith acknowledges he didn't make a
scene he says any father would have done
the same he said i went nuts i called
the principal a p word six cop cars
showed up like an effing swat team to
respond to the school's complaints about
an assertive parents he said thank god i
drew enough attention to it without
getting arrested that we got an escort
to the hospital and they administered a
rape kit that night
a sane exam in buckle swab his lawyer
said came back later favorable to the
prosecution's case
all juvie records are sealed the
sheriff's office declined to release
records relating to smith to the daily
wire but in response to a public request
record public records request confirmed
that a report with offense forcible
sodomy and sexual battery matching that
date and location exists
at 4 48 on the day of the incident the
principal sent out an email to the
community that claimed nothing
jeopardizing student safety had occurred
painting smith is the villain and
offering counseling services for
witnesses of smith's blow up the letter
said quote
good evening stonebridge families this
is stonebridge principal tim flynn there
was an incident in the main office area
today that required the loudoun county
sheriff's office to dispatch deputies to
stonebridge the incident was confined to
the main office and the entrance area to
the school there was no threat to the
safety of the student body the incident
was witnessed by a small number of
students were meeting with the staff
adjacent to the main office counseling
services and the services of our unified
mental health team are available for any
student who may need to talk about
today's incident
lcps washed their hands at the smith
said it was only taken seriously because
of the sheriff's office
the lcps director of communications said
only that quote any information related
to student information is confidential
under state and federal laws regarding
student privacy
lancaster this lawyer told the daily
wire she accompanied smith's daughter to
meetings with prosecutors that the
suspect made self-incriminating
statements in an interview that
prosecutors brought the charges and that
a conviction was expected imminently
likely in the form of a plea deal to a
charge of felony aggravated sexual
battery
smith had not opposed the downgrade
saying about the boy what if he made one
mistake
on june 22 the school board held a
meeting where the focus of discussion
was a proposal expanding special
protections to transgender students
smith showed up out of practical
concerns
my wife and i are gay and lesbian
friendly smith said we're not into this
children transgender stuff the person
that attacked our daughter is apparently
bisexual and occasionally wears dresses
because he likes them so this kid is
technically not what the school board
was fighting about the point is kids are
using it as an advantage to get into the
bathrooms
from the dais school board member beth
bars painted such concerns as paranoia
and prejudice
our students do not need to be protected
and they are not in danger she said do
we have assaults in our bathrooms or
locker rooms regularly
superintendent scott ziegler replied to
my knowledge we don't have any record of
assaults occurring in our restrooms
board chair brenda sheridan asked have
we had any issues involving transgender
students in our bathrooms or locker
rooms
ziggler answered
time magazine in 2016 called that a red
herring that the data was simply not
playing out that transgender students
were more likely to assault cisgender
students in restrooms than other
students
smith tried to contain himself as the
activists who prioritized had lived
experience and believed women ignored
his daughter
nearly 250 members of the public had
signed up to speak
many of them were critical of the school
system's racial and transgender
initiatives others were supporters of
the transgender policy who painted their
neighbors as ignorant bigots with one
saying hate was dripping from the
followers of jesus in this room
opponents booed at the remark the board
threatened to stop the meeting if
participants were loud again
after another speaker blasted the school
board for suspending a teacher named
tanner cross for speaking in opposition
to a transgender proposal the crowd
cheered and the board shut the meeting
down
two courts later ruled cross had to be
reinstated
apparently
after a far-left board member bart's was
elected in 2019 with 55 of the vote she
lashed out at parents who disagreed with
progressives and teachers union-backed
policies so often and with such vitriol
that most of her peers who agreed with
reviews censured her and stripped her of
her committee assignments bart's then
retreated to a facebook group officially
known as the anti-racist parents of
loudoun county later known to critics as
chardonnay antifa
and she started targeting people in the
parent community
who were questioning the loudoun county
school board
okay but this
apparently came to a it's sort of
logical apex at this june 22nd meeting
apparently
one of the parents confronted smith
okay because smith was talking about
what had happened to his daughter
a parent named jackie schwarm confronted
him
schwarm was at the june 22 school board
meeting wearing a shirt with a rainbow
heart on it as a girl scout troop leader
jazz had mentored swarm's daughter
smith and jess just as the wife said
schwarm sought them out in the crowd
demanding to know which side they were
on and berated them they were in the
wrong
jazz who was this smith asked his wife i
thought she was my friend jess said
smith tried to tell her what had
happened to his daughter he said and she
looks me dead in the eyes and says
that's not what happened
schwermann noticed that smith was
wearing a shirt with the name of his
plumbing business on it and she goes oh
i'm going to ruin your business on
social media
you're a b-word smith told her video
shows a police officer monitoring the
tension-filled exchange pulled on
smith's arm he yanked it away and soon
smith and the officer were wrestling
just cried out in words lost in the
chaos my child was raped at school and
this is what happens smith was charged
with disorderly conduct and resisting
arrest
swarm this this rival parent actually
did a 40 minute phone call with the
daily wire and contended she had no
relationship with the topic
that she didn't have any sort of
argument with smith and didn't know he
had been arrested
after the daily wire offered evidence of
her involvement she said she went over
to ask just for a play date between
their teenage daughters
she claimed she asked jess how she was
doing switch just purportedly responded
we know critical race theory isn't real
but we don't want them to know it
schwarm told the daily wire that if
smith's daughter told him she was raped
by a martian she would believe her but
she also made repeated comments about
the daughter's mental stability
as to her comments on the facebook group
she told the daily wire the group was
apolitical that she had never taken part
in list making activities
and then she started calling other
parents racists
after swarm repeatedly brought up that
smith was convicted of a crime the daily
wire asked if a restorative justice
circle a technique pushed by progressive
prosecutors as an alternative to
punishment would have been a positive
resolution to the arrest
apparently schwarm then said she did not
know what restorative justice was and
wasn't interested
okay this entire thing ended up on
national tv
and the entire story ended up being a
story about how smith was a terrible
person who is trying to terrify members
of the school board
and the prosecutor decided to go forward
with the case and try to prosecute smith
and throw him in jail for all of this
smith said nothing as his likeness
traveled around the world the avatar of
ignorant bigotry advisers told him it'd
be better to let the process against his
daughter's assailant play out he didn't
want to risk interfering
the culprit was expected to plead guilty
on october 14th but then there was a
second case
in which apparently the same teenager
was charged with forcing a victim into
an empty classroom where he held her
against her will and inappropriately
touched her
the daily wire is withholding the name
of the suspect because of his age
reached at home his mother declined to
comment on the allegations
so here is the bottom line two girls
allegedly sexually assaulted in school
four months apart by the same person so
far the only person to be convicted of a
crime is the victim's father a school
policy passed following what appeared to
be false statements from the
superintendent the superintendent said
that nothing bad had happened at school
that is not true
the prosecutor bibaraj has not returned
a request for comment
though the injection of politics into
schools and criminal justice have led to
pain where there was none before and
enemies where there were once neighbors
it is possible some elected officials of
loudoun county might actually believe
this story has a happy ending though
smith's daughter has been allegedly
raped and separately beaten at school
the teen has adopted increasingly strong
progressive views over the course of her
tenure at lcps where did she get these
ideas from school obviously said yes
it's not from our home
okay that's the craziest story of the
day but unfortunately this is part and
parcel of the the issues that we are
told don't matter we are told that
parents are not supposed to worry about
this that educators are going to be
handling the education of your children
that the school boards ought to be is
what terry mcauliffe says in virginia
and that if you have any serious
questions about this if in fact your
child has suffered at the hands of this
ideology
then you're making it all up it's all
fake that is what we are being told and
in fact perhaps you're in league with
domestic terrorists we'll get to more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about a simple fact if you run a company
you need to make sure that your hr is in
order you start off as a small company
never think about human resources
because that's like toby from the office
but here's the thing if you ignore it
liability crops up pretty darn quickly
you need to take care of hr and hr
manager salaries aren't cheap they're an
average of 70 000 bucks a year
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e was created
specifically for small business you can
get a dedicated hr manager craft hr
policy and maintain your compliance all
for just 99 bucks a month with bambi you
can change hr from your biggest
liability to your biggest strength your
dedicated hr manager is available by
phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business and
help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
they're month-to-month no hidden fees
you can cancel any time you didn't start
your business because you wanted to
spend time on hr compliance let bambi
help get your free hr audit today go to
bambi.com shapiro right now to schedule
your free hr audit that is bambi.com
shapiro b-a-m-d-e-e dot com
shapiro today make sure that you get
your hr taken care of because if you
don't it's going to come back and bite
you go check them out right now
bambi.com right now to schedule that
free hr audit
now if you're concerned about any of
this stuff happening in schools then
you're the bad guy right this is the
gaslighting of the american people we're
told that this stuff is not supposed to
matter
so for example
the one of the editors over at axios
margaret talev
she said on cnn that if you're worried
about critical race theory in schools
you really shouldn't be because it's not
happening right none of this stuff is
happening you're just imagining all of
it
let's just say for the record just in
case anyone doesn't know they don't
teach critical race theory to kids in k
through 12 schools that's not a thing
anywhere in the country including in
virginia but setting that only for
republican candidates yes but it is it
is highly debated but not actually a
thing it is actually a thing as it turns
out the 1619 project which is now growth
of critical race theory is being taught
in schools all over the country you have
the national education association
passing resolutions talking about the
importance of critical race theory to
pretend that critical race theory is not
taking place in our schools is just a
very simple form of gaslighting
it's a game that the left likes to play
where they boil down complex ideas into
very simplified versions of themselves
and then they put them into
indoctrination centers across the united
states and then if you protest they say
well
that that what we're teaching there it's
not the complex forum and the complex
form is what you're talking about
they call you crazy and then if you go
to a school board and you protest maybe
they call you a domestic terrorist
there's a piece by a woman named marone
over at barry weiss's sub stack barry is
doing better reporting than probably
half of the major media in the country
here is what maude maron writes quote
i'm a mother of four a criminal defense
attorney and a lifelong liberal who is
deeply concerned about the direction of
new york city's public schools i've been
outspoken about my views along with an
untold number of frustrated parents for
that the fbi is considering using the
patriot act against me let me explain
late last month the national school
boards association an umbrella
organization representing thousands of
local elected school board officials
sent a letter addressed to president
biden it warned that america's public
schools and its education leaders are
under an immediate threat but not just
any threat quote the classification of
these heinous actions could be the
equivalent to a form of domestic
terrorism and hate crimes the letter
implored the white house to enlist the
support of homeland security the fbi and
the doj to investigate the threat adding
the alleged crimes fall under the
purview of the patriot acts in regards
to domestic terrorism says maude marone
i read the letter with grave concern as
would any american who cares about our
public schools and the safety of
teachers and students what was the
nature of this threat would my own
children be at risk as it turns out the
threat is me the threat is parents
showing up to dress down school boards
over their dereliction of duty
the letter
has 24 foot notes the worst of these
so-called crimes that require the fbi to
investigate domestic terrorism and the
doj to activate include prank calls an
individual in ohio yelling quote a nazi
salute in protest of masking
requirements another individual in
washington state whose disorderly
conduct prompted the board to call a
recess spreading misinformation online
and disorderly conduct arrests
in new york disorderly conduct is not
even a criminal offense and yet within
days of the nsba letter the top law
enforcement official in the country a.g
merrick garland publicly responded to
the letter with a memorandum to the
director of the fbi agreeing with the
nsba that quote there has been a
disturbing spike in harassment
intimidation and threats of violence
against board members without providing
any evidence the fbi's clear message to
parents is that the nsba is on the right
track
says maude marone many of the parents
who are on the receiving end of the
federal government's chilling message
are new to school boards new to speaking
up and to say the absurd part out loud
clearly not domestic terrorists
the combination of extended coveted
related school closures mass mandates
and increasingly extreme race and gender
focused curriculum the removal of tests
honors classes merit-based admissions
has created a bumper crop of engaged and
in many cases enraged parents rightfully
concerned about what is happening in
their children's schools
i've witnessed some of the viral videos
myself and some of the meanings over the
last four years i have actively
participated in many raucous school
board meetings where board members and
even the new york city school chancellor
have been shouted down by parents who
refuse to be ignored i've never raised
my voice to make a point but i have sat
next to those who have they are sincere
parents exercising their civil liberties
i also know what it's like to be on the
other side of the table i was elected to
two consecutive terms on manhattan's
largest school board in what is the
nation's largest school system
ultimately i became board chair as
school board chair i was harassed
bullied smeared subjected to online
campaigns demanding my resignation it's
not fun to listen to people call your
names or falsely accuse you of racism
but when you're elected to a school
board slide you have an obligation to
listen to everyone at public meetings so
i listened
i never would have considered their
activism to be something best handled by
the fbi
you may disagree with parents like me
who do not want our children
indoctrinated with critical race theory
masked during recess or told their
biological sex is not real but in a free
society we don't call the feds to police
our fellow americans because we don't
share their politics
okay this is exactly right but this is
the war the war right now is between
people who believe they should be in
unquestioned control of your life and
everybody else
and people are fighting back okay the
gap is creating a backlash and you're
told by folks on the left that none of
this matters but i'm not sure what
matters more to parents than the fate of
their children and the indoctrination to
which they are subjected
the left has lost touch with the
american people they're setting
standards
on the basis of radical woke politics
that no one can uphold
most americans look at stories in the
news and their first
innate thought is how does this apply to
me that really is how people view the
news right which is why economic issues
tend to outweigh things like climate
change for example right how does this
affect me in my daily life well you know
what's something that affects you in
your daily life how your kid is treated
at school
whether you put yourself in the shoes of
a parent who's had a child abused at
school and then apparently ignored by
the school
whether you put yourself in the shoes of
a parent who doesn't want their kid
indoctrinated
in a government center
and then told to sit down and shut up
and that all of their worries are mere
conjecture
right parents are fighting back against
this sort of stuff
they should be fighting back against
when we when we apply the headlines that
the left would like to apply to our
lives when we apply those to our lives
many of us look and we get
and we get fearful and there's a good
reason for that we should be upset and
fearful at the standards the left is
setting which are not standards at all
this is the point there is no consistent
standard it is not about standards at
all in the first place and so when
there's blowback and the left ignores
the blowback they are cruising for a
bruising because they are setting
standards then no one can hold they're
basically saying that they get to set
every moral standard in the country and
if you have any questions at all you're
crazy
you're crazy or you're violent you're a
domestic terror threat or you're a
racist sexist bigot homophobe you
shouldn't care about the fate of your
kids you should just put the fate of the
country and your children in their
expert hands
we'll get to more on this in just one
second because this is the pervasive
sense across all of american culture at
this point the left sets standards that
are not standards and only apply to a
particular set of people and everybody
else as long as you go along with their
agenda you're fine we'll get to more of
this in just one moment first let's talk
about a simple fact
you need life insurance if you're a
responsible human being you need to make
sure that you have life insurance i mean
let's say that you decide to set sail on
some sort of massive boat voyage
let's say that you're on the safest boat
right you didn't get insurance because
you're on the very safest boat that has
ever set float and then shockingly the
boat hits an iceberg and you find
yourself stranded in open water clinging
to a floating door
but there's someone else on the floating
door let's say that it's someone you're
interested in and that person could just
move over like this much and you could
live but instead
instead decides to take up the entire
floating door and so you're just there
freezing to death and as you're sitting
there freezing to death the frostbite
setting in your blood pressure lowering
as you begin to die you think to
yourself man really should have listened
to shapiro and gone to policy genius
even though i was in fact on the safest
boat afloat policy genius makes it easy
to compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
you could say 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius it could save 1300 bucks
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
the licensed experts at policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process that kind of service has
earned policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot and
google
and eligible applicants can get covered
in as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes advisor higher than options from
ladder ethos and bestow getting started
is simple first you head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need compare personalized
quotes to find your best price and then
policy genius handles all the paperwork
and scheduling for free head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro gets started
right now policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice and quite important
to get it right okay so
we are now having the left set standards
that are completely anti-parent
and the blowback is coming but the left
is going to pretend that it shouldn't or
that it doesn't exist and they are
simply out of touch
there's a piece in the wall street
journal today by william mcgern talking
about how parents are fighting school
boards
harry jackson left the fairfax county
school board meeting thursday night
feeling frustrated the father of a
thomas jefferson high school sophomore
he had signed up to address the board
about sexually explicit material in the
school library including work he and
other parents say normalizes pedophilia
but the list of speakers ended right
before his two minutes of the mic a
student who did speak that evening
defended the contested material saying
quote there's nothing that is
inappropriate unless you go looking for
it mr jackson takes it as a backhanded
admission i'm glad to see we agree
there's pornographic material in the
library he says
thomas jefferson isn't just any public
school u.s news and world report ranks
it number one in the nation and jackson
isn't just any parent earlier this year
he was elected president of the school's
parent-teacher student association a
graduate of the us naval academy a
retired naval intelligence officer he's
one of thousands of american parents
taking on their school boards across the
country
like many of those rallying outside
thursday nights meeting jackson wore a
t-shirt saying parents are not domestic
terrorists
all this has transformed once dull
school board meetings into increasingly
raucous encounters between parents and
officials
on so many of the hot button issues of
the day from mass mandates and lockdowns
to critical race theory transgender
policy and racial preferences for
admissions the public schools have
become the vanguard for today's
progressive agenda but parents such as
mr jackson aren't taking it anymore and
they show no signs of relenting
and this is right the blowback is real
and the blowback is going to continue
and democrats have a problem here
because they cannot allow the blowback
to continue the party base is owned by
the most progressive radicals and this
means setting standards that no one can
possibly uphold and alienating the
swathes of the american public democrats
are cruising for a political bruising
here even if they refuse to see it
ian ward has a piece for politico that's
quite fascinating today is an interview
with david shore so david shore you'll
recall
is a a data analyst who
was essentially out ousted from his job
last year because progressives got super
angry at him because he wrote a piece
pointing out that riots don't actually
help your political cause that riots
actually are counterproductive and
result in people not liking what it is
that you're pushing
and for that because it was in the
middle of the black lives matter riots
he was thrown out of his job david shore
well david shore who's at least an
honest and he's off the left right he's
an honest analyst of the left
he says
that
essentially the democratic party is now
being held hostage by an electorate that
is too radical for the rest of the
american population
quote at its most basic david shore's
theory goes something like this although
young people as a whole turn out to vote
at a lower rate than the general
population the aforementioned type of
young person is actually overrepresented
within the core of the democratic
party's infrastructure
right those would be young people who
are highly progressive in their politics
right the sorts of people who have
gay pride flags on the back of their
computers and list their pronouns and
and believe that america is deeply
according to shore the problem with this
permanent class of young staffers is
that they tend to hold views that are
both more liberal and more ideologically
motivated than the views of the coveted
median voter and yet they yield a
significant amount of influence over the
party's messaging and policy decisions
as a result democrats end up spending a
lot of time talking about issues that
matter to college educated liberals but
not to the multiracial block of moderate
voters the party needs to win over to
secure governing majorities in
washington
shore says quote it is descriptively
true that people who work in campaigns
are extremely young and much more
liberal than the overall population and
also much more educated i think this is
pushing them to use overly ideological
language to not show enough messaging or
policy restraints and from a symbolic
perspective to use words that regular
voters literally don't understand and i
think that that is a real problem
this is of course exactly right
and the fact is that the the motivated
young liberals who are
really creating policy and pressure
inside the democratic party are pushing
the democratic party incredibly far
outside the mainstream
and of course shaw isn't the first one
to say this according to politico in
2015 the political scientists ryan enos
and ayton hirsch published a paper in
the american political science review
analyzing the results of a survey they
conducted among staffers on obama's 2012
re-election campaign
based on the results of their survey
enos and hirsch concluded that in the
context of the campaign widely
considered most adept at direct contact
individuals who were interacting with
swing voters on the campaign's behalf
were demographically unrepresentative
ideologically extreme cared about
atypical issues and misunderstood voter
priorities
this is exactly right and here is the
thing the people you're most likely to
hear from not just inside the democratic
party but in the halls of media power
agree with the radicals
the media is young it is overrepresented
in terms of progressivism
it is ideologically loaded it is people
who are college-educated white people in
the main and those college-educated
white people are coming out of college
just as woke as they were when they left
college and they go into the newsrooms
and then they start covering politics in
exactly the same way and the american
people feel it and i've been told by
people on the left the culture wars
don't matter the culture wars matter i
think to a lot more people
than even questions as far as how the
government is going to spend your money
the reason being on a day-to-day level
how we treat one another how we interact
with the institutions of daily life how
the media cover us and our values that
matters an awful lot to us
there's a lot to be said for the idea
that the culture wars are more important
than some of the economic wars that the
culture wars being upstream of
everything are in fact the key to
everything
and when you watch every major
institution of the country twisted
toward the cultural left and then you're
told that you have to be excluded
because you're a redneck
you're going to respond pretty badly to
that as well you should
and this has ramifications for nearly
every major cultural story in america
today a group of privileged elites who
have basically decided they are going to
educate the american public about what
is best and they're going to use utterly
unpalatable standards in order to do so
because they have to teach you
what is right and what is wrong they are
your moral betters
whether it is at school boards or
whether it is in the halls of media they
are going to teach you you are a dumb
ass and they are the they are the elect
we'll get some more of this in a second
because this has pretty broad cultural
ramifications first let's talk about the
simple fact that you don't need to waste
time in the post office okay the post
office is great but do you really want
to wait in line schlep all your packages
over there or wouldn't it be better to
just do all of this stuff from home or
at the office this is why we here at the
daily wire have been using stamps.com
since 2017.
have you got a small business you know
there's nothing more valuable than time
so head on over to stamps.com because
you can send letters and packages for
less with discounted rates from usps ups
and more
since 1998 stamps.com has been an
indispensable tool for nearly 1 million
businesses stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups shipping right to your computer
whether you're in office sending
invoices or a side hustle etsy shop or a
full-blown warehouse shipping out orders
stamps.com will make your life easier
all you need is a computer and standard
printer no special supplies or equipment
within minutes you're up and running
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere you want to send it
and you'll get exclusive discounts on
postage and shipping from usps and ups
as well once your mail is ready just
schedule a pickup drop it off no traffic
no lines cut the confusion out of
shipping with stamps.com's new rate
advisor tool you can compare shipping
rates and timelines to easily find the
best option save time and money with
stamps.com there's no risk with my promo
code shapiro you get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and the digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
head on over to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in promo code shapiro that is
stamps.com promo code shapirostamps.com
never go to the post office again
already tonight huge night for backstage
instead of our usual daily wire studio
we will be live streaming our
conversation on stage at the famous
ryman auditorium right here in nashville
we will attempt to make sense of the
increasingly authoritarian world we are
living in this will be an event and a
live stream unlike any other we have
done we are thrilled to be able to share
it with all of you plus we'll be making
some extremely exciting announcements
you're not going to want to miss it it's
going to be an awesome event i know
people are super pumped about it join me
candace owens jeremy boring michaelmoles
matt walsh andrew clavin and our live
audience for a backstage like you've
never seen before tonight's live stream
will begin at 8 30 pm eastern 7 30 p.m
central so head on over to dailywire.com
or dailywireyoutube to catch the show
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
okay so your cultural leaders in every
institution are people who believe that
they are better than you and they get to
cram down their values on you whether
we're talking about the loudoun county
school board which ignores an alleged
assault on a 15 year old girl in order
to promote their agenda or whether
you're talking about the nfl higher ups
and the media who have all decided that
standards that are unreachable by any
human being must be held up as these
standards now let's be real about this
the elites have one standard for
themselves and they have a standard for
everybody else and what they are very
fond of doing is a distraction technique
and that really is what it is it's a
distraction technique where if they
throw out a piece of red meat for the
other elite then you will ignore their
own sins
if you just if you if you make a human
sacrifice every once in a while the gods
of wokeness are propitiated
which is exciting stuff
well today's story of the
this is how it works right is that if
you do something that is just woke
enough you do something that's just woke
enough then we'll ignore the fact that
you have participated in all the systems
that you claim to cry there's a great
example of this that happened over the
last 48 hours an interview with axios
from the founders of ben and jerry's ice
cream so remember that ben and jerry's
ice cream is this uh you know they're
very very left leaning and they decided
they were essentially going to boycott
israel they're going to remove their
stamp of approval for ben and jerry's in
israel because the israeli government
has promoted quote unquote settlement
activity namely jews being able to live
in historic judea and samaria and ben
and jerry is a wild leftist company and
so the two founders of ben and jerry's
who are a couple of bernie sanders
vermont socialists who are not
socialists at all they're very very
wealthy they're asked a very simple
question by axios okay the simple
question is it's weird you're willing to
boycott israel but i see that you are
very very happy to have your shops open
in places like texas and georgia and
florida why is that
and the answer here that they're never
going to give is because wokeness is
selective right being a far-left elite
socialist
getting to proclaim your moral
superiority
as long as you do it in like little
doses everybody will ignore the fact
that you are a willing participant in
capitalism and quote unquote
exploitation
you guys are big proponents of voting
rights why do you still sell ice cream
in georgia
texas abortion bans
why are you still selling there
i don't know
i mean i mean it's a it's an interesting
question
i don't know what
what that would accomplish
we're working on those issues of voting
rights and
i don't know i you know i mean i think
you ask a really good question and i
think
i'd have to sit down and think about it
for a bit you know the answer the answer
is because they make a lot of money a
lot more money they're making in israel
they make a lot of money in georgia and
florida and alabama and all the rest
they make a bunch of money over there
but so long as they appease the gods of
selective wokeness by being the leaders
of selective wokeness then they are
better than you
and this is the way that it works and
this is the story of the nfl today so
john gruden
has had to resign from his job as the
coach of the las vegas raiders
for vulgar language
and bad old emails and these are emails
from 2011 to 2014. now you may have
checked your calendar recently and
noticed that it is actually the year
2021 and also you may think to yourself
wait a second so these were private
emails leaked apparently by somebody at
the nfl to the media and john gruden who
signed a 10 year 10 100 million dollar
contract
in 2018 is about to lose 70 million
dollars in contract money because of bad
old emails that were revealed by
somebody inside the nfl offices
now i've been reliably informed by the
left that leaked emails are super bad
we're not even talking here about hunter
biden just leaving his laptop out there
we're talking about like leaked emails
are bad right wikileaks is bad all these
emails are bad private emails are
private right i mean i thought this was
the standard except when it applies to
somebody that is perceived as quote
unquote right wing right which is what's
happening to john gruden right now and
now this is not to say that everything
in john gruden's emails is wonderful and
good it isn't there's a bunch of stuff
in there that's kind of bad
also if you've never met an athlete or
been in a locker room or spoken to a
bunch of testosterone ridden 21 year old
men and you're going to pretend that
what john gruden was writing in his
emails is anywhere close to the top 80
of the things that are bad that are said
in the locker room you're out of your
damn mind
but john gruden is going to lose his job
and the nfl is going to declare that it
is it's woke right you remember that
football was gay you remember football
became gay last year right they put out
a commercial about how football was gay
now how many football fans actually
think of football is gay right foot
that's not a thing that is designed at
marketing toward the average football
fan that is designed at marketing toward
the woke left which is then going to
give the nfl a pass
on all of the rest of its insipid
vanities and and terrible acts
and the reality is that the nfl is rife
with alleged criminality as well as
serious internal racial problems and the
way that you distract the woke left the
beautiful thing if you're if you're a
wonderful left-wing capitalist at the
top of the elite structure you can just
distract the woke left by throwing out
one of these human sacrifices every so
often so here's the story from the new
york times quote john gruden stepped
down monday as the coach of the
of the las vegas raiders football team
hours after the new york times detailed
emails in which he had made homophobic
and misogynistic remarks following an
earlier report of racist statements
about a union leader his resignation was
a striking departure from the football
league for a coach would won a super
bowl than a marquee analyst on espn and
returned to the nfl in 2018 to lead the
resurgent raiders which he had coached
years before
i have resigned as head coach of the las
vegas raiders he said on twitter in a
statement issued by the team i love the
raiders and don't want to be a
distraction thank you to all the players
coaches staff and fans of raider nation
i'm sorry i never meant to hurt anyone
mark davis owner of the raiders said in
a statement he had accepted the
resignation
rich vesachia the raiders special teams
coordinator was elevated to interim head
coach according to the team
gruden's departure came after the new
york times report that nfl officials as
part of a separate workplace misconduct
investigation that did not directly
involve him found that gruden had
casually and frequently unleashed
misogynistic and homophobic language
over several years to denigrate people
around the game and to mock some of the
league's momentous changes
hey so in other words the this entire
report by the nfl was done because there
were allegations of sexual harassment
inside the washington redskins now the
washington football team structure
they they called some 650 000 emails
including private emails from gruden to
people who are inside the washington
redskins now washington football team
structure
okay and
then the nfl decided that they were
going to leak these emails to basically
destroy groot now i have a question for
you put aside what gruden says in the
emails
do you want to live in a world where all
of your old emails hacked at any time
could be the reason for your downfall is
that the world you want to live in first
of all expressvpn.com go check it out
right now and protect your data but
beyond that are you really interested in
now being in a situation where there is
no distinction between public and
private private emails are just out
there for everyone to see and we can
unleash our selective outrage on anyone
we choose at a moment's notice for pure
convenience
because let's be real about this
john gruden's old emails are like
problem number 193 on the list of nfl
problems
okay here are just a few of the people
who are currently playing in the nfl and
their alleged crimes like actual
criminal activity not bad old emails in
which you use the f word for gay people
which by the way apparently matt damon
is allowed to do that's exciting right
matt damon is so important that he's
allowed to use that word until like last
year and everybody just goes well you
know we do like him as an actor but john
gruden used it in 2011 in an old email
and he has to be fired
okay so here are the people in the nfl
who are currently playing
bradley chubb who's injured for the
denver broncos he failed to appear for a
court date on misdemeanor traffic
charges near denver
deontay harris is injured but is still
active with the new orleans saints he is
suspected of drunk driving reckless
driving and speeding richard sherman was
recently signed by the tampa bay
buccaneers
he apparently has been accused of
domestic assault because he was accused
of crashing his car in a construction
site and trying to break into his wife's
parents home
zavin collins of the arizona cardinals
is active he's been accused of excessive
speeding and reckless driving
frank clark of the kansas city chiefs is
still active he's accused of having a
concealed submachine gun in his car
josh jacobs of the of the las vegas
raiders of that very team is currently
active he's accused of driving drunk
after a car crash
but
at least they didn't send old emails in
referring to michael sam in denigrating
language
now that's super important and by the
way the nfl itself right is now
the base is now experiencing major
lawsuits from black players because it
turns out that the nfl had used race
norming assuming black players start out
with a lower cognitive function
in trying to determine whether players
had suffered from cte and brain injuries
see an entire sport that is based on
people bashing their head into things
and people getting concussions
and then people getting brain injury
from that and the nfl was assessing
black players differently from white
players
roger goodell still has his job i've
noticed
but at least they didn't send any
battled emails from like 2011 2014
gruen's departure came after that new
york times report that nfl officials as
part of a separate workplace misconduct
investigation found that gruden had
casually and frequently unleashed
misogynistic and homophobic language he
denounced the emergence of women as
referees
the drafting of a gay player and the
tolerance of players protesting the
playing of the national anthem
ah
gruen's message messages were sent to
bruce allen the former president of the
washington football team and others
while he was working for espn as a color
analyst during monday night football
okay so this wasn't even when he was
working for the raiders this is when he
was working for espn
in the emails gruden called the league's
commissioner roger goodell
the f word okay well there's only one
problem roger goodell isn't gay right so
we we now have a standard
whereby using the word
the f word that is slur applied to gay
people to
using that against non-gay people is now
apparently
about targeting gay people
he also called raja goodell a clueless
anti-football p ward and then said that
goodell should not have pressured jeff
fisher than the coach of the rams who
draft queers a reference to michael sam
a gay player chosen by the team in 2014.
that's ugly stuff that's vulgar stuff
then in the top 99 of what's been
happening in locker rooms around the nfl
like today and anybody who thinks that
it has is out of their mind but i guess
it's worth 70 million dollars 70 million
again the reason this is a story is
because everybody in america sees this
kind of story and they think
what's in my emails
what's in my texts
i mean
like apparently it is now safer in the
nfl to be a repeat
alleged sexual offender than it is to
have bad old emails is the way that this
works
and then everybody will overlook the
fact that the nfl continues to be a
rather exploitative
place know this this push by the elites
in our society to basically control
everything that you do and then gaslight
you about all of it to set standards
that are utterly unreachable by anybody
because again
to me and so i think most people this
isn't about the bad things that john
gruden said is in his emails the problem
is the standard you're now holding
people to which is that if you said
anything bad in private ever
ever and it is ever substantiated and it
is adjudicated to be bad ten years after
the fact
you could lose your entire career and
you can be destroyed and that's what's
going on with john gruden right now
because if you're matt damon and you
just come out and apologize for it
because you said it yesterday you're
fine but if you're john gruden in the
nfl needs a distraction from the where
are the other 650 000 emails by the way
i've noticed that the only emails that
have leaked are about john gruden
what about the nfl can we see roger
goodell's private old emails can we see
the old emails from the executives at
espn by the way if you want to look for
bad behavior at espn i mean there are
still historic figures at espn who have
been described as engaging in rather
reckless behavior who are still
commenting on the nfl like day in and
day out
but this is the idea right is that your
culture has been the way that your kids
are taught the way that we are all
subjected to a group of people who get
to determine like cody's sitting under a
palm tree whether you ought to exist in
the society or not it's pretty
incredible and if you protest any of it
or if you notice any of it this means
that you're crazy
the hijacking of institutions to to push
this sort of stuff out is amazing
and so for example
you're seeing this right now with uh
with dc comics so dc comics is now
attempting to essentially gain some
attention for their uh for their
comic books and they've been doing this
for a while by increasingly relying on
wokeness now the reality is that the
comic book audience is a bunch of
teenage to young male
readers
predominantly straight
and the dc comics gang over there is
interested in hijacking
iconic american figures and then using
them for social justice purposes and
that is the goal here they're not
building new characters with new
personalities who are woke instead
they're taking iconic characters and
they are just
retrofitting them in order to push
wokeness and then if you notice that
then it's because you're bad right
you're not supposed to notice any of
this so it is cultural elites attempting
to tell you what morality looks like and
to shape the minds of young teenage boys
and then tell you they're not doing that
or if you notice that they're doing that
why do you even care
like that that is the silly game that
plays stupid games win stupid prizes
that is why superman is now coming out
as bisexual
which is very exciting stuff the new
york times says up up and out of the
closet the new superman jonathan kent
who is the son of clark kent and lois
lane will soon begin a romantic
relationship with a male friend dc
comics announced on monday that same-sex
relationship is just one of the ways
that jonathan kent who goes by john is
proving to be a different superman than
his famous father since his new series
superman son of kal-el began in july
john has combated wildfires caused by
climate change forwarded a high school
shooting and protested the deportation
of refugees in metropolis
don't worry guys the cultural arbiters
they're not attempting to affect your
kids in any way they're definitely not
attempting to cram down a particular set
of values on you and if you notice that
they are it's because you're bad
it's because you're bad so make sure you
don't say anything about it for sure
don't say anything about it because if
you say something about it they'll come
after your career and destroy you
if you notice that they are attempting
to control how people think if you are
to hijack mainstream
cultural figures and then twist them
into social justice warriors
well then that's because you're
intolerant and bad and bigoted these are
the better these are the best people by
the way it doesn't matter
whether
warner brothers and dc con it doesn't
matter what any of these people do in
their business doesn't matter how they
treat people doesn't matter they do
business with china the key is they're
pushing the cultural factors that make
them the elites and you not the elites
which is why you need to shut up and
pretend that none of this matters to you
and you have to just wave your hand and
say well you know that's just the way
the culture goes now
the left fights culture wars because the
left's culture wars are the ways that
they change how people think it is the
threat they use to cuddle people into
silence it is the standards they use to
take control already we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content coming up soon is the matt wall
show it airs at 1 30 pm eastern be sure
to check it out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavo
wiedowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show